kevin
[Music]
where's my pen blood
remember last year we would hang round
ends
last year and you came up to me and you
asked me can i use your pen
i was like sure of course i've let it
out before
and i've always got it back by 18 no
more
next time that i saw you it was all
kinds of awkward
i didn't want to ask you straight out
thought that i'd be too forward yeah
it been two weeks by then what you hope
i forgot it while you had hands on my
parker
right there in your parker's pocket my
mom's gone by and still you ain't giving
it back now my anxiety mountain
because that wasn't just some viral man
that thing was a fountain
now you got me doubting like you're no
longer making me just know you keep my
stationary
i'll leave you stationary why'd you even
need it cuz
what are you even signing we've been for
instance primary and you can't do joined
up writing
i got that pen for my birthday that's a
right of passage
and since my pen's been missing i can't
write a passage
i want my pen i lent it to you
and now i ain't seen it again i want my
pen
give me back my pen like a striker going
down in a box
i want my pen look it's been eight weeks
at this point this whole thing's
affecting my life
i'm worrying that you broke it and you
won't make it right
and even if you gave it back even if it
weren't deliberate
what if you used up the cartridge that's
just inconsiderate i'm spinning these
bars with a dome
they're coming straight from the crown
that was the only pen that i owned
so i couldn't write my rhymes down think
i'm overreacting
like why you gotta take this hard we
just had my grandma's 80th and i
couldn't even sign a card
it was the ultimate pen and i don't mean
second to last when i was bored in class
it got unscrewed and taken apart
just bring it back apologize i'm sure
we'll make amends
but if you chewed up the end you'll get
chewed up in the end
your mum not teach you manners why all
this impermanence you've got 10 days to
return it cause
that's when things get turbulent i'm
talking turkish
chopped up like saudi journalists when i
step to you in my sharpie
leaving a mark that's permanent talking
about a knife cause i want my pen
i lent it to you and now i ain't seen it
again i want my pen
give me back my pen like a homeless pig
i want my pen you told me that you'd
give it back in a minute blood it's been
six months
this is why nobody likes you this is why
they call you
own up to your rudeness waste man you
got no balls like ken
next time that you borrow something give
it right back like trent
should it never let you have it in the
first place never let you take it off of
me
you should have stuck a pen in your
windpipe amateur tracheotomy
should have drawn with you brick with a
brick to the blood and your neck drips
out
like a kid that chokes on a pen lid
you'll get capped in the mouth
no pen do penance i'll make sure you are
dead
you'll have red on you sean of the dead
dead you've had your final warning
so now i aim for the head and turn you
into a pencil
full of lead pens my ear then the sword
is in my ear than my nine
you're less like real neat writing on
the line
i'm coming around there with a gap for a
chat and you know that i'll take what's
mine wait
hold up it was behind my ear the whole
time oh
no way i got my pen
i lent it to you and now i found it
again i got my pen
you clearly returned my pen i got my pen
back
yeah i'm in sorry i threatened to kill
you kevin
you